THIS YEAREALLYE THE YEARF
THE INDEPENDENT.
JOHN AVLON WITH Y CHECK.
EN OURERRT
E ARE FIHA
DEMOS  REPUBLICANS
W KECOS HERE CTIVE
DEIS
ACTUALLY OIF THEY WIN,CHANGE TH
THEY WOULD LIK SEE TO THE
NOW, I SATN O E CANDES ABO
CHOSE THISATMcMUS  CITENA
ALLY.
S
THIDED TO STEP
MISHAW SCHOOL GDUE D EIR OW
THE REPUBLAN, S  FACT THAT F
IDENTIFY AS INDEPENDENTS.
GO THEN A DEMOCRATIC OE STATSLE
REPRESENTING A RURIS
ITAL.
OUEAR FROM THESE DENDCANDID
SEE TH HS
THE DEE SEEMED TO AKS AREN'T BE
BE THE BEST ROUTE.
DL.
41% OF NORTH DAKOTANS IDENTIFY
WE HAVE TO TAKE THE BEST OF BOTF
OUR PEOPLE.
TH ABLE TO RN.
T WE HAVE
GOT NDEPENDENTLEADERSHIP AT ALLL
ASUENCES THA
THEM AY FROM SIMPLY SERVING
THE INTERESTS OF THEIR PEOPLE,
SPECIAL INTE GS OR EMIST FACTIO.
OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS FIRST.
>> WUAEDM RUNNING TO
FROM THE IDEOLOGY AND TH
E EXTREME
TICAL PARTIES IS AER
FOME.
N A REFT
THEM WHE GOT TOO E
ON ISSUES I CAREABOUT,E  GAY
I THEN FOUND A
WRI
T STRANGER AND SR
DEFUNDINE POLICE, ALLOWINGKE PE
FRANK TO IPA
PERIOD OF URBAN
YOGOVERN GET THROUGH LD OTHERWI.
RUNNING TO B
CONGENIALITY, I'M RUNNINET
STUFF DONE AND I THINKLY
SORTISANS, BOT
AND RsE THE COVER OF
ANR SAYING
ITOKO S
OKAY TO
TH O BUDGE
AND POLICYRS.
DY T
SENATORS OF
PARTA S PARTISAN, ROUP ITHE SEN
THAT HAVN REALLY EVERY
MA T
PIECES OF LEATE
THE LAST MONTHS.HE
I  PART IT WILL GIVE THIS COIO
THIS STATE, TREMENDOAMNTCRRA
YOU? PARTY SE YO
OR IS THAT OVETA
IT IS NOW DOWN TO JUST MAND
THE REPUBLICAN INCUMBENT.
VERY CLEAR THEY ARE NOT
, THEY'RE NOT
MEAN HAS
LES THAT I
DISAGREE W FIRST
U Y TO GET THEIR  AND THAN GO
$5,000 AND THE
YOU CAN'T OR SEETHT
FOX
J FURER
DIVIDE THAIF YOU AGREE
WITH US,U'RE NOT WELCOME
WITH JUSTHAY.VEA COMPETITIVE NA.
BUT THAT'S WHY W DOING DIFFERENY
BUT WE CAN ONLY DOT IF WE HE PO
TRUTH.
RACE, I  TPRINCIPLED  I GOT INS
REPUBLICANS ANDE
LEADING INDEPENDENTS IN UTAH AO
CANDIDATES.ANHAWE WER T
WH
S THAT YOU THINK
ANETR INDEPENDENT ATEN IN THE P
>> PARTISAN GRIDLOCK.
THEY'RE SICK OF THE FI>> I DON'
CONTUEINK THIS YOUNGER GENERATN,
INDEPEEN
WET ACTAON'TNT THE GAMES BACAN
FAR RIGHT MOVEMENT THAT WANTS TO
UNRAVEL OUF
THE EXTREMES OTHE ENDS
OF THEAL SPECTRUM IN
GENERAL HAVE BECOME FAR TOO AN
EITHER WE WERENG
ROLLED BY THESEXTREMES, AN
OUR STATE AND OUR COUNTRD
CONTINUE TE WERE
A COALITION CENT AROUND OU
RE I
INDEPENDENCE.
INDEPENDT G TOEA THRE
OWNEFITED FROMTYSTRUCTURE OFTEN
PARTY CANDIDATE OR
INDEPENDENT IN ITS G
SPF ONY.
IT WASINGINOSD
IN A WAY IT'S A TWO-PARTY STATEE
TERWHELMINGLY PUBLICAN S